جامعات ايران تنتفض مجددا بعد ما قاده
الاحتجاجات في بدايتها ففي جامعه امير
كبير لتكنولوجيا بالعاصمه طهران نظمت طلاب
اعتصاما احتجاجا على اعتقال السلطات عددا
من زملائهم جامعه طبطئي في طهران ايضا
احتجت طلاب بطريقه خاصه حيث زينوا كليه
الاداب برمودا برتقاليه بمناسبه اليوم
العالمي للقضاء على العنف ضد المراه في
جامعه اصفهان للتكنولوجيا الاحتجاجات لم
تكن صامته ولا رمزيه حيث تظاهر الطلاب
وردته تفاهات ضد النظام الايراني طلاب
جامعه العلوم والثقافه بطاهره نظم احتجاجا
تضامنيا مع ابناء محافظه كردستان ونبددوا
بقتل قوات الامن للمتظاهرين في المحافظه
من جانبها شهدت جامعه خرز خوارزمي مسيره
طلابيه تضامنا مع ابناء محافظات ايرانيه ت
احتجاجات ضد السلطات وبالتزامن مع مظاهرات
الجامعات الدراما محتجون النار في مقر
للبسيج بمدينه
بارزجان في محافظه بوشهر وحرقوا صوره
لقاسم سليمان في مدينه قرشيك جنوب طهران